do
[Music]
[Applause]
up not me
I
[Music]
need I
need I need you I'm in the shadow the
shadow of sun I Bel something come on
I'm in the shadow of the shadow of the
sun oh when I need you I'm in the shadow
the shadow of the sun I
Bel the Shadow the Shadow the
sun oh when I need
[Music]
you
I
[Music]
need oh when I need you
oh when I need
[Music]
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
we
I'm in the shadow the shadow of the sun
I Bel something on I'm in the shadow the
shadow of the
sound oh when I need you I'm in the
shadow the shadow of the sun I belong
there something come on I'm the Shadow
the shadow of the
sound oh when I need
[Applause]
[Music]
you
when I need
[Music]
you
need I need
[Music]
I
oh